I was expecting more of you
you're unskilled untrained
and
and unworthy
forgot one Unstoppable
oh
my God
it is my destiny to do what my ancestors
could not to restore the ultimate power
to the home of my people
ultimate power
ultimate power
my language
don't play dumb with me Apprentice of
long claw you knew long claw no glory
and her people were the sworn Enemy of
My Tribe the Echidna we fought and died
at the hands and now you will die at
night
come on get in I'm on your side I'm
sorry who are you
you know what it doesn't matter
yeah
[Music]
make sure to get your shot egg man
[Music]
wow okay let me just say it is an honor
to finally meet you Sonic is it okay if
I call you Sonic everyone calls me Tails
you're probably wondering why let me
guess because of the extra tail that's
right I should have known you'd get that
cool also what is going on robotnik's
back and Clifford The Big Red Rage
monster that's Knuckles the last of the
echidnas and the most dangerous warrior
in the Galaxy he's obsessed with finding
the Master Emerald are you serious the
Master Emerald that's just a bedtime
story well he believes it's real and he
must think you're the key to finding it
give me the wheels
[Applause]
oh I think we lost him
we definitely did not lose him
foreign
do you trust me of course not I
literally just met you what are you
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're flying uh did your butt just turn
into a helicopter
a quadcopter oh only Sonic the Hedgehog
could come up with something like that
let's split up you go high I go low
right quick little stretch and here we
go
[Applause]
obviously you want to play
that's new
foreign
[Music]
it's too easy come on challenge me
[Music]
we are talking Style
I make this look good
oh great the Winter Soldier
for a guy named Knuckles you are
you are bad at punching surrender the
compass you're a no match for me I've
been training for this my entire life
and I have no training at all yet here I
am ahead of you that's gotta be
embarrassing
my rings
my destiny is to protect my friends and
family I think I just threw up in my
mouth
and if you want that Emerald you're
gonna have to go through me
[Music]
[Music]
the Echidna is taking no presents today
Sonic has Hearts but will he lose the
quill to live
I don't want to fight you but you're not
giving me much choice
too easy
let's do this
[Music]
all right
don't you stand still and Die With Honor
let me think about it okay I thought
about it
hi there beautiful
you're the real deal aren't you
say goodbye Hedgehog
stop robotnik's stealing the emerald
what kind of fool do you take before
just look my
wait that wasn't the deal
poor naive creature
it's not your fault
a more advanced intellect would have
seen this move coming a mile away or 1.6
kilometers but I trusted you
you were my friend
I'm sorry that just hit me funny
let this be my final lesson to you you
dim-witted Celestial skin tag
friends
and vulnerable with each other which
means x squared times the hypotenuse of
Y squared divided by the absolute value
of friendship equals dookie oh no
chaos
is how
foreign